that's the name of this successful
Ethiopian band
it means ours in Amharic they want to
belong to their fans as their music
stands for social change and women's
emancipation our lyrics have deep
meanings and are informative we address
important issues you know the five women
don't just make music they make films
and have their own talk show and radio
play in their show each one plays a
certain character a year Rosalyn is the
ambitious one Zim Biba is the music
lover tariff is the city girl Rahel
plays the maternal one and LEM LEM is
the street child everything is prepared
intensively it's very important to us
that we write the script after visiting
a place we do field research first in
order for us to tell the true story
really una story no power - there was
also a workshop called girl and journey
we went there in person to try to
understand how they really felt and what
kind of life they lived hidden colonies
and that's our Harriott iton yemen feel
and America each characters problem is
based on reality
domestic violence forced marriage and
poverty these are issues that many girls
in Ethiopia can identify with genja
presents different perspectives and
approaches to the problems affecting
young women the work has changed the
Biba when I see a woman on the street
with these problems I don't just walk
past I go up to her and try to speak to
her besides everything begins at home
it begins with respect for your family
your sister Sonia has changed me in many
ways
a casting brought the band together
three years ago since then they've been
all over Ethiopia and have become real
celebrities their work reaches about 7
million radio listeners but they're
still down to earth they like to have
regular contact with their fans I want
to be happy like them they're loved just
everything about them makes me happy
Jenya doesn't just want to reach girls
or women for them equality involves
everyone
that's where twenty-eight-year-old
Zelalem casaya comes in he plays the
male friend who works with the girls for
women's rights that way they reach male
listeners like hairdresser Tariq alum
when I heard that many women and even
mothers get hurt my attitude towards my
sisters and my mother changed I didn't
know that women were getting raped times
have changed now even mothers are
getting beaten and raped Yaya is
changing young men's attitudes towards
women the group is excited about their
fans they give them the feeling that
they're on the right path